it's nice to have interesting people
come to your house and I think that they
my theory is that they infuse this place
with their energy and there's a there's
a certain light kind of permanence to
that that I feel like with every guest
that comes like this place becomes
better I like that I and also I think
just having people in your home it makes
them relax a little bit I think it makes
them relaxed and I think it makes them
see view you as it makes it easier for
this to be a conversation cuz I'm in
your home I'm not just sitting back
waiting for you to interview me like a
reporter this is your home how long have
you lived here since we built the house
2003 it's 2000 so you were still doing
the loitering yeah yeah I mean I I
lawyer I mean I was slowly kind of
weaning myself off of the law up until
2012 the last couple of years I wasn't
doing very much of it but yeah I was I
was I was a lawyer here for the first
several years and you'd commute all the
way into LA no I mean at that point I
had opted out of the big corporate law
firm life and then I had a variety of
different iterations like I was a I was
a solo practitioner and then I had a
couple partners for a while and then I
had a different partner I had an office
in Beverly Hills for a while I had an
office in Santa Monica and then I just
worked out of the house on and off as
well so but also you know in those
iterations like I didn't really have a
boss so I had more flexibility so it
wasn't like the nine-to-five type of
commune here that that that commute
downtown every day like I don't know how
they do that because we live pretty far
out there how far away is downtown from
here we it depends it's all about
traffic as you know it can be two hours
or it can be 45 minutes depending but
our eldest daughter she's a sophomore in
high school she goes to a high school
that's east of downtown now and the
commute is just to own or us so we have
an apartment that we rent in downtown
and my wife and I split the week staying
down there with her and
homeschooling the other one good for you
I think that's yeah both of them work
have been homeschooled on and off and I
know you have lots of ideas and thoughts
about education specifically college and
all that I think we've talked about that
before yeah although I'm just curious as
a side like for probably the main
question you're asked about this is the
socialization because obviously
homeschooling she's gonna learn more
from you than in some crappy high school
but in terms of friends and
socialization does she get that yeah I
mean that's something that comes up all
the time and that that's something I
worry about the least because our house
is like it's like a functioning studio
there's just people here all the time
like all different kinds of interesting
people so in terms of like social
stimulus like that's the least of my
worries I I do get concerned
occasionally about you know basically
pure academics
you were from not high school I know it
is it's basically just my the
programming of my upbringing that kicks
off and creates resistance around it
like I always ask people okay I've even
asked this to people who like majored in
college in like European history and I
say okay when was Charlemagne born and
this is the most this is the guy who
united Europe or whatever is the first
great king of Europe and probably 95%
you know any and by the way we've
studied it it's been in textbooks every
year since like sixth grade and if you
majored in European history you should
definitely know it but 95% almost a
hundred percent don't get it right
within five hundred years right I don't
I definitely could not answer I don't
even really remember right now and I've
asked I've even written about in Iver
acid millions but I think it was around
754 give or take people will say 1,400
1,300 they won't know yeah and and I'm
like okay well what else can you have we
learned in school every single year
there's nothing else I took French for
five years I can't say anything other
than Bonjour and I can't even count I
can't even count to ten and I took it
for five years including in college
right what we do need to do though is
reconfigure the priorities of Education
around learning how to learn and
learning how to make decisions and
learning how to interact with people
like life skills that transcend pure
memorization I mean you were
looking at Shane Parris this book here
on sitting on the table he was in here
the other day and his whole thing about
mental models was grown was born out of
this realization that nobody had ever
taught him about the methodology of
making good decisions like it says
that's there's no course in business
school or in college or in high school
about that and yet that's something that
all of us need to do a zillion times
every single day yet not only make
decisions but avoid the biases that are
like almost biologically built into our
brains to prevent us from making good
decisions right you know and and from an
evolutionary point of view there was a
reason for it like if you heard if you
were walking by a bush and you hear this
rustling you would start running because
for good reason maybe there's only a 1%
chance as a lion and a 99.99% chance
it's you know just win through the
bushes but you can't take the chance so
you just run but we end up making we're
staring at a screen all day now and
we're getting those same instincts and
so we're making decisions based on those
statements there's no lion in the in the
computer but like if a stock goes down a
little bit and you're looking at the
stock market or if someone says you're
an email you don't like you get that
same thing like I'm gonna just kill
somebody or run and and you don't know
that these are just biases that have
been there for a million years yeah yeah
I mean it it's it's certainly true and
I've been victim to that many times well
we all can't help yeah like something in
your body or mind is reacting to
something in a visceral way and so if
you lean into that
there usually is some creative output
that you could produce so I remember one
time this is a crazy little experiment I
did I I wanted to play around with what
are formats to write an article so
everybody just writes and posts it on
LinkedIn or their blog and they write a
little you know 10 reasons to do this or
whatever and so I wanted to come up with
I've been playing around for 20 years
different formats of writing so I said I
want to do something I never did before
and Donald Trump had just tweeted I'm
gonna buy Greenland right
I'm thinking twins up that's really
weird like I didn't even know you could
buy a country and so I figured okay
let's that something about this feels
weird
of course and then and then the
president of Denmark or I don't know
they'll leave the prime minister of
Denmark he tweets back it's not for sale
and this is like the weirdest auction
I've ever seen on the planet like the
president itíd states like wants to buy
this massive piece of land and I didn't
even know Denmark owned Greenland and
he's like it's not for sale
so that also was a weird comment like
why it would buy the ultimate trol when
Trump tweeted that picture of one of his
hotels like did you see that like I
definitely won't do this and it was a
picture of like a Trump Tower like on a
on a barren like Greenland landscape
that that's so funny that he did that
and something but I didn't even see that
which would have definitely set me off
but just these two world leaders like
bantering in this way like this about
you know people live there you know it's
this huge piece of land there's all
these natural resources where what how
did Denmark end up owning Greenland I
said from like Eric the red a thousand
years ago like what is going on here and
so I started to research it and I
thought okay there's some weird things
going on with Greenland that I ain't
know about so I learned I learned a lot
about Greenland and then instead of just
writing an article I had never done a
Kickstarter before so I decided to do a
Kickstarter which so I said okay I'm
gonna raise a hundred million dollars so
I go buy Greenland and I wrote all and
instead of writing in order by rote just
all the reasons why I want to buy
Greenland why people should let me buy
it as opposed to Trump or some other
country and and then I had you know with
kick so you have to put all the rewards
like so I said okay fifty dollars you
could be a citizen a hundred dollars
I'll make you an earl yeah a thousand
dollars you could be a Duke yeah
carving out all this like acreage for
people and and and I was able to list
though all the reasons why I thought
this was interesting like there's a lot
all these rare earth minerals and
there's a company called Greenland
Natural Resources which is actually a
hundred percent owned by China yeah so
this is again another we're China now is
that during the picture and there's all
these weird things I didn't know I
didn't know Kickstarter and
and to this article quote-unquote that I
had now published on Kickstarter versus
a normal place will start to get shared
everywhere and so that was interesting
for me and then Kickstarter shut it down
and so they shut it down because I'm
obviously not people start donating
money right and Kickstarter and then go
fund me the same experience they shut me
down because I'm obviously not gonna
raise 100 million so they they and
they're on they have to pay all the
charge backs to the credit card
companies so it could be a big money
loser for them so they just shut it down
but then I had a second story which is I
was just shut down by Kickstarter and
GoFundMe and so the whole thing is
here's a little experiment and I gained
a huge amount from it without any cost
to me so I learned all this stuff about
Greenland I learned about kicks I'd
never done a Kickstarter before so
suddenly now I knew how to do a
Kickstarter I spent some time studying
best crowdfunding practices and I
learned about Kickstarter and and then I
learned this new format I could write
articles in which was weird and then I
had a second story on top of it was that
they censored me and here's what
happened so just that small impulse
allowed me to experiment in ways that I
wouldn't have been able to otherwise and
learn a whole bunch of things that now I
can do a Kickstarter now I can speak
intelligently about buying Greenland or
whatever and it's super funny yeah it's
funny it's like right
wait what like first of all you know can
a country by another country yes or no
can an individual by a country and
what's interesting is that you got shut
down
not on the merits right of what you were
attempting to do but on kind of a side
technicality which was probably
motivated just by extreme discomfort
right but at what was going on and there
them trying to figure out like we got to
find a way somehow to shut this down yes
people were like sending money in like
they were like wiring money in and so
the sheer audacity of the whole thing
yeah it it's not dissimilar from and I
know you've talked about this as well
Richard Branson saying saying give me
you know going to Boeing and saying give
me an airplane
ya know that's a great guess so
ridiculous that they would do that but
there's something about where naivete
meets audacity you know an audacious you
know dream and then some steps are taken
that that's how anything amazing is
created well there's so many layers of
you can't do this involved in ever any
creative act because if there if people
weren't telling if people weren't saying
rich you can't do this then a thousands
of other people probably would have done
it by now so it's it's it's kind of
finding where people are saying you
can't do this but when you ask yourself
why there's no real reason might as well
try it right so like with this there's
no reason why I couldn't start a
Kickstarter raise 100 million dollars to
buy Greenland and I learned something
and you know all the times like people
say oh well you know you can't start a
podcast have you ever done interviews
before or a radio show like leave it to
the professionals no I think I can do it
like why can't I do it and you know I'll
tell you another just quick experiments
not as it's not as interesting as
Richard Branson Richard rants is really
an interesting example because this is a
27 year old guy who was a magazine
publisher and had no experience with
anything relating to Airlines British
Airways had a monopoly in England on
Airlines Heathrow only dealt with
British Airways and Richard Branson's
didn't have money and he simply calls up
Boeing and asked to borrow a plane they
give it to him I mean the details I'm
skipping over the details they just lend
him a plane for a year he throws like
yeah you could use this one landing
strip we don't really use that much
same with JFK and suddenly he has a
plane going back and forth like you know
that every I'm short every step of the
way people were saying to him are you
insane and but what does it hurt to ask
and then of course there's subtleties
there's skills - asking and how did he
ask and all these things that he used
skills learned from being a music
magazine publisher but still it's this
combination of skills with audacity with
you know like why can't I and allows you
to go forward on so many different
different things right I think both
those examples Greenland and the Richard
Branson example are illustrative of both
of these books they well the book that
you have out now think like a
billionaire in the book that you have
coming out next year called skip the
line like
there are there are lessons in both of
those examples that could be pulled from
both or either of those books oh yeah
absolutely because let's say well let me
ask you when you were starting to run in
marathons and then ultra marathons and
Ironman things and you were in your mid
forties I bet you there were a lot of
people saying to you rich maybe you
should just stick with a 6k or whatever
there are plenty of that plenty of that
I but I look at it as sort of the the
the frog in the warm water that's coming
to a boil slowly like there is an
incremental like sort of compounding
path that you can take towards towards
like an athletic goal that's different
from I mean I guess I did skip the line
and that I didn't do all that little
stuff and I went right to like ultra
distance and didn't pay my dues or
didn't didn't take that 10k what's an
athlete like I can I mean look I can
minimize it but yeah I guess for
somebody not steeped in this world it
does sound like a little insane and
ridiculous it was a same rich yeah like
you were you weren't an athlete then
right no I had I had a past as an
athlete right in high school but
logically yeah like rationally on paper
like it didn't make sense and so and yet
look what happens you you ran you know I
don't I don't know the exact the ultra
iron whatever on every island of Hawaii
you know one day at a time you do these
you did these incredible feats sometimes
for many people every step of the way
kept telling you can't but that's what
puts you on the other side where you
suddenly if you go past enough of you
can't do this then suddenly you're the
only one doing it and so you were the
only one in the world who had the kind
of resources and set of experiences
instead of talents that you had where
you were running in all these races but
you were also you know you know going
towards this vegan lifestyle you had the
experience of being a lawyer so you were
able to you know you had a better
capability of writing about all these
experience than most people would so you
were able to combine them all into being
the only rich role out there doing these
events
books podcasts you were there's no one
who can compete yeah well I think
it's an example of having all of these
skills in a variety of disciplines that
I tried over the years that weren't
necessarily matched up with with like my
ultimate talents and certainly not my my
passion or a sense of purpose that when
they finally found the right outlet at
all that congeal to create you know an
amazing result in the same way that you
know somebody was to say to you like you
don't have the credentials to be a
podcast host but many years ago you did
your 3 a.m. show you learn how to talk
to people you learn how to create
something that's entertaining you are
doing stand-up comedy like you've done
and you've been writing you've all of
these other areas like all contribute to
your ability to sit behind a microphone
and be engaging and be entertaining and
be curious all these skills that you've
developed over the course of a lifetime
I mean I would say similarly I took I
took a million depositions as a lawyer I
learned how to ask questions and I think
that my my that my true skill set as a
podcaster was developed through sitting
in thousands and thousands of AAA
meetings listening to people tell their
stories and learning how to tell my own
story that was my training ground for
being a public speaker and being a
podcast host you learn how to be
empathetic you've learned how to listen
you develop this is this great capacity
for compassion for the human condition
that I think lends itself towards
creating a safe and an interesting
environment to explore those very themes
with another person sitting across from
you yeah I think I think that's so
interesting because I think that does
come across like your compassion for
your guests comes across so much in your
podcast I think because of your
experiences and you know I always wonder
about this idea that vulnerability like
the kind you experience in a the kind
you experience in or one should
experience in writing and maybe all
forms of art vulnerability sort of buys
freedom like when you're vulnerable when
you're able to admit to what can go
wrong what has gone wrong with you in
the past the mistakes you've made now
you're free like nobody can say well you
can't say this you've done this and I
yeah I said that I'm
idiot a lot of the time bring it on and
you're free you don't have to deal with
people saying well rich you can't talk
about health you had this and this
happen to you when your 20s alright yeah
read my book it's in it already yeah
yeah so you're free from from all that
stuff in the more vulnerable like how
can people you know attack that I can't
say well now you're not allowed to write
about this because you experienced no
there's no rules and and yeah I'm just
being authentic and that allows me to be
as creative as I want in this area I'm
creative even about my mistakes well
your specific strain of authentic
vulnerability was really a tipping point
in your creative career like when you
finally made this decision that you were
gonna be honest and write about it write
about your life and your experiences in
a very transparent way I'm sure there's
a lot of fear that preceded that but
when you mustered up the courage to do
that that's really when things change
for you oh yeah completely and to the
point that now I don't even like if I'm
writing something I don't publish it
unless I'm afraid of what people are
going to think of me and I don't try to
say something that's gonna I just asked
myself at the end right before I hit
published is this am I really saying
something new and unique here because I
don't want to say something that
everyone else has said or am I saying
something where I'm really afraid oh no
water is what our X Y & Z gonna think of
me what are these people gonna think of
me what are my friends gonna think of me
what are my readers going to think of me
so I I I always have to double-check
myself because if you're not afraid of
what you're creating there's a chance
then that okay everybody else has done
it because they weren't afraid either
right and so there's got to be some
resistance somehow that you get over
like even something I wrote recently I I
was legitimately afraid well is this
gonna shed a new light on everything
I've written for the past ten years
because I'm omitting to this other thing
and I was I was nervous incorrectly so
but that's okay that's that's that's how
you learn is is getting over that every
time yeah when I wrote I think I
probably told you this previously but
when I wrote finding ultra like I really
had to get into the mindset
of writing in my private journal that no
one was ever going to read like I had to
get comfortable communicating things
about my life that I'm ashamed of and
that I'm embarrassed about and I
remember when I sent the manuscript to
my editor at the publisher I looked at
my wife and I just I said I hope I'm
making the right decision like this
could be the worst decision I've ever
made
but I knew intuitively that the value of
the book would be directly correlated to
the extent to which I was willing to be
vulnerable because why do it otherwise
you know and I think you know my book
finding ultra is it's an addiction
recovery memoir it's also like this
sports story and it's also kind of like
a health and wellness primer but but
ultimately it could be categorized as a
sports memoir and like I hate sports
memoirs because they're all they're
usually written by athletes in the
twilight of their career and they're
intended to kind of create a halo effect
and and and perhaps buy them a couple
years in the spotlight and that's why
they're not good because they're
inherently less than honest and I've
never won a race it's not like I went to
the Olympics or anything like that like
why should anyone care what I have to
say about this the only reason that this
the only way that this is going to be
compelling is if I you know take my
specific experiences and try to connect
with something more Universal about the
human condition and that can only come
through you know a profound level of
honesty
yeah and that and that happen you
created something very unique which was
this sort of combination of kind of a
sobriety memoir health and wellness
athletic memoir plus a reinvention
memoir so you were in your 40s where a
time when people think well that my
knees are starting to hurt maybe I
shouldn't run marathons anymore there's
a lot of people are thinking like this
of slowing down and you were literally
speeding up at that point and I think
you gave permission to for people who
were reading it to say oh yeah he
stopped being a lawyer to do this he
stopped you know he became sober and
then this started happening I went vegan
this started happening he's in his 40s
and he's doing all these athletic
competitions it's sort of like you gave
permission not only
other people to be equally vulnerable
and I'm sure you got lots of messages
like man I was in the same situation as
you and so on in it but you also gave
people permission to hey I could if he
could do it I could run a marathon or do
something incredible when I'm 45 that I
never thought I could do before and I
think that's something like I'm curious
now like when you're thinking that that
was a very pivotal story for you right
and it's an iconic story like I was you
were saying essentially I was down and
out then this happened and then I became
a superhero so this is like a this
iconic story do you feel do you ever
feel like tied it's that story like you
have to keep repeating it or find a new
story do you ever give or grapple with
the whole that story now has over you
versus what this told you originally had
on that story yeah a hundred percent and
I've worked really hard to kind of
transcend that a little bit certainly I
think I think when the book came out it
was sort of characterized as a book
about running which it isn't it's not
about becoming an ultramarathon or it's
very much' choose yourself story you
know it's a family it's about the
inherent power that we all have within
ourselves to you know basically shift
the trajectory of our life even if we
find ourselves in our 40s or in our
later years that that inherent capacity
lives within all of us to tap into you
know a more a deeper reservoir of human
potential in whatever way you know feels
right to you and I think it took a long
time for that message to kind of
percolate out of what was considered to
be a running book but then yeah I felt I
wouldn't say trapped I think that's too
strong of a word but you know this sense
of being like oh you're the vegan ultra
athlete like yeah that's something that
I did but it's only one aspect of Who I
am and the podcast very much is about
it's not about me it's about my guess
it's about it's about the next chapter
if the if the book was gonna have you
know an epilogue like okay now what like
I leveraged some tools to grow and
manifested this thing that I talk about
in this book but that growth continues
that's not the end of this
I want to continue to grow if I could
make these changes what other areas in
my life am I currently blind to so let's
go on a journey to explore that with the
smartest most interesting people that I
can find and that has nothing to do with
my story and everything about you know
the wisdom that's available in the world
and and so now you've interviewed
hundreds of really amazing guests a lot
of them kind of athletic but not all of
them you know your a lot is about
wellness but again not not all that it's
it's all people who have captivated you
or interested you for various reasons
and I'm um I'm only asked you this so
I'm debating this so I've also
interviewed hundreds and hundreds of my
heroes and you know authors who are you
know passing through the city so I get
to interview them and so on and and I've
interviewed many you know people I've
just always looked up to and I'm
starting to wonder okay after five
hundred of those maybe sometimes I want
to just say what I think about things
rather than just always interviewing
people and and so I'm kind of going
forth on that of mixing that up a little
not completely but just mixing it up so
it's not you know there's two million
interview podcasts out there now when we
were just talking about this earlier
when we were in 2014 there was like a
hundred interview podcast now there's
literally two million I'm not even
exaggerating it and okay and we've also
interviewed everybody and so now we
haven't interviewed the whole planet but
we've interviewed a lot of people so
people start repeating things or saying
similar things and then but I'm sure
your audience they're listening to you
for a reason and maybe they want to
start hearing more of what you have to
say about a topic and I wonder if you've
ever debated doing kind of more solo
stuff yeah I mean a couple thoughts
first of all both of us have been doing
this for a while I started mine in late
2012 you've done more episodes than me
but I started a little bit ahead of you
yeah there's been a lot of overlap in
our guests
we've been on similar journeys indeed
when we started it was not a competitive
environment both our shows went right to
the top and kind of stayed there and in
the intervening years this medium has be
has has been adopted in a very
mainstream way so the ecosystem has
matured tremendously around us we were
both lucky enough to grab a little piece
of real estate and hold on to it but you
know I I certainly want wouldn't want to
be somebody starting an interview based
podcast now I say I think it would be
very very difficult to do that so I'm
extremely grateful to be in the position
that I'm in and I'm sure you feel the
same way but you know here we are and
I'm interested in your thoughts - I'm
gonna throw this back to you like what
is the state of Union in you know with
this medium and as somebody who thinks
about things in a counterintuitive way
and with a different lens like you know
what is the future of this and you know
I'll continue to answer your question
and allow you to answer that when I'm
done I think that you know I had Kamal
raava Khan over here yesterday your good
friend and we were talking and we were
talking about your show and I said to
Kamal I go I tune into Jane like James
has lots of interesting people on a show
but I want to hear James like I I'm
fascinated by your you're like your lens
your perspective on the world and you're
the reason that I tuned in so I think
that that is a smart and appropriate
pivot for you to start to have more
standalone episodes with just your
reflections and your thoughts in my own
case I have thought about that the
hardest part of this whole podcast thing
for me is tweet me introductions like
when I'm alone talking into a microphone
I'm so up in my head and it feels so
unnatural so the idea that I would sit
down and just deliver a monologue you
know spontaneously from whole cloth even
if I had an outline that's like that
scares me and I feel like that is a
skill that I haven't yet honed and
perhaps that's a reason to attempt it or
to experiment in the sense that let's
say you have just someone sitting here
who's listening and occasionally maybe
instead of like in an interview it's
let's say 50/50 but let's say in this
case you need a file yeah oil you you
need someone who you're just gonna throw
things against and if something doesn't
quite stick they'll inform you of it
yeah like a like a more than like
you know a co-host but somebody who you
know can like match your wits and push
you to deliver a monologue you yeah like
let's say there's me go ahead so let's
say there's an issue that you know
triggered that emotional impulse for you
this week so something happened that
bothered you and you just wanna and and
and you wanted to talk about it but not
necessarily the issue but even more
globally like what does this mean for
either the world or people or what did I
learn from this or the economy or
whatever and you just start ranting on
it yeah and I do have a little bit of an
insecurity around it I think here's an
example so last year we did our first
like live podcast event we booked this
big theatre and we sold it out it was
like 1,200 seats that's great and the
idea was to do a live podcast and and
but also produce a show that was very
you know that kind of transcended this
podcast format to create an entertaining
experience for people I had my son's
played music and then in cue perform
some live poetry and then I did a live
podcast with Paul Hawken who's like this
legendary environmentalist and I
conducted that podcast very much as if
he was sitting across from me right now
like I kind of maintained that format
and after the show was over I basically
went you know out into the hallway and
just talked to people for as long as
they wanted to talk to me and I was
there for hours and hours and hours and
I realized in retrospect oh these people
like I think they're coming to see Paul
Hawken you know and and I realize like
oh they they're there they are coming to
see me which makes me uncomfortable like
I doesn't feel like I've because I have
profound impostor syndrome like I can't
imagine why anyone let it come to see me
but so the growth for me is in is in
owning that and and and and living up to
that on some level that that you know I
have had certain life experiences that
have value and that there is something
interesting about sharing you know my
perspective yeah or what if you even
went on Twitter beforehand and you said
listen I'm gonna try this solo episode
thing but give me some fuel
be a bunch of questions and then you
pick the four or five that you like the
best and can even just do a 20 minute
episode or attach a story from your life
to each question along with the answer
and/or your answer and that's an episode
right yeah I think I'll probably try
that I think I'm I'm I wouldn't say I'm
in a rut but I have we have like a
routine now and yeah I know how it goes
and it's working and and you're somebody
who's coming in as you know like this
disruptive force who's like always you
know got the waiter pads and you're
writing down the ten ideas every day and
you're like trying to buy Greenland and
you're doing all the crazy stuff and
what I love and appreciate it appreciate
appreciate about it isn't just the the
kind of courage to do it it's your
relationship with the outcome I feel is
very healthy like you're not it's it's
not about whether it works or not you're
just doing it right because here's what
I always think is that something's going
to work some outcome will exist that I
like but it doesn't have to be the
outcome of whatever it is I'm doing that
day so I'm doing something let's say
today or tomorrow or the next day I'm
doing something to try something new or
try an experiment or write something
eventually
the outcome might be bad like for
instance this Greenland Kickstarter
thing and again this is a silly example
but that was essentially a failure I
didn't raise 100 million dollars to buy
Greenland Kickstarter shut me down and
it was fast enough it didn't really get
as widely spread as I has a successful
outcome would have been but it was
interesting I learned something I
learned a whole bunch of things and then
you move on because you know that's
missing story yeah I have amazing story
and now I have knowledge okay I here's
how to do a Kickstarter if I want to try
something up and so now I can do the
next thing which might be just as crazy
or not and the outcome may be good may
be bad eventually there'll be some
outcomes will be better than others but
I'm whether the outcomes bad or good
learning from each thing right you've
canonized this as the 10,000 experiments
role we talk about the 10,000 hour rule
you're like that's nonsense let's focus
on 10,000 experiments and cuz Dad yeah
cuz I so the 10,000 hour rule which
you know was developed by great guy
professor Anders Ericsson he basically
determined if you devote yourself to
10,000 hours of what he calls deliberate
practice at any field you'll be among
the best in the world at that field and
this was written about by Malcolm
Gladwell in the book outliers and it
kind of became a popular phrase after
that I just couldn't wrap my head around
it though because I feel like I've
gotten good at a bunch of different
things and I don't think I've spent
10,000 hours at them and I couldn't
and for some things I couldn't figure
out what does he mean by 10,000 hours
like I understand with let's say you're
you know doing a golf putt I can
understand practicing that for 10,000
hours and you'll get better at golf
putting but for something like writing
what does it mean to spend 10,000 hours
writing like this there's there's so
many nuances in a creative field and
this it's not like repetitive it's not
like I can get a coat after I write a
sentence I can get a coach and say well
that sentence could have been better so
I didn't really and I would write to him
and he's always very smart he was always
very friendly to respond and I read all
these different theories like can I
borrow hours from this other activity so
I was trying to get good at stand-up
comedy I started this it's a random
thing I saw was got passionate about it
about five years ago started going up on
stage and I was trying to figure out can
I borrow from my 10,000 hours public
speaking and some hours from my writing
and some hours from just I don't know
being funny or how does it work and so
transferability yeah these these skills
in a variety of disciplines can you
aggregate them to come up with your
10,000 hours yeah at least give me some
head start and he and he kept writing
about what's the metric you're judging
yourself with and there's really no
metric like how do you determine if
something for instance is good writing
or not is it's book sales no is it if
your favorite professor likes it no it's
hard for creative efforts it's hard to
have a metric of success for many for
for sales ability for business ability
there's so many like other factors like
luck environment the people you're
dealing with that there's it's hard to
to measure your success with these
10,000 hour
and and it was confusing talking him so
then I figured well maybe there are and
then the other thing that concern me was
well what if you take training methods
now and go back to the 1920s so for
instance if someone took people who
coaches who train for marathons and took
those same techniques back to the 1920s
on coaching techniques for so we're not
as advanced what would it be then a
hundred hours to be the best in the
world you know the hours change
depending on how advanced the field is
so I more things kept coming up that I
didn't really understand and that's when
I started thinking of another model
completely to measure my own success and
then to increase to accelerate my own
learning in different fields and so I
was I was very excited by that because
it basically took me two or three years
to be a good solid professional investor
it took me two years to achieve a level
I wanted and let's say a game like chess
which is normally a hard skill or a
computer programming which is a hard
skill and then with with with stand-up
comedy also I didn't you know I'm I was
48 years old at the time I'm 52 now I
didn't want to go 10,000 hours or 20
years to get good at something that
doesn't I don't want to be on stage and
I'm 68 years old trying to make a bunch
of strangers laugh like it feels silly
to me I just wanted to get good at it
now I wanted to literally skip the line
everybody kept telling me don't think
you can skip the line like with stand-up
comedy like they're very you know
respect your elders and that's very much
you know you got a grind and and pay
your dues yeah median will be like you
got to go up there and bomb a thousand
times you know and and just keep doing
it and keep doing it and keep doing it
and in ten years you'll be good yeah 10
best case is what they would say and
here you are like you start basically
telling jokes on the subway right yeah
so I you're headlining right what is the
time period it's it's basically about
five years but like four years since I
started taking it super seriously where
I would go up two or three times a week
and more recently you know up to ten
times a week so but yeah I had to
construct I had to really be very
analytical about it and I would
deconstruct every comedians axle I would
understand what they were doing and then
I would explain it back to them and they
were like huh I never thought like that
which is fine like they were they have
their process but then I started
constructing experiments I can do to
basically accelerate my learning and I
found every experiment really changed
the way I would do comedy so I would
start really a people would see me from
one month to the next and I'm like boy
when did you start doing X Y or Z and
I'm like after this experiment I did
where I saw these other things weren't
working uh-huh and sometimes the
experiments are very simple like between
jokes what if you just leaned back
against the wall and look up at the
ceiling for three seconds or four for a
half a second like so just even an
experiment like that because there's
this feeling on stage that you have to
spit everything out as quickly as
possible or you know you mentioned one
experiment I did I went on this so I
wanted to tighten up my one-liner so I
went on the subway and did stand-up
comedy on a crowded subway cars where
nobody wants to hear you tell jokes
nobody likes you nobody is in in the
best case I can towards getting a laugh
is very hot right they're not they
didn't just pay a cover charge to see a
comedian they just want to get home like
you're bothering them at that point and
they're not drinking so they want a
drink
some of them might be right some of them
might be and most of them want to drink
and then this person just gets on the
car and starts telling jokes straight at
them and it was it's very difficult but
that did you get some laughs oh I did
yeah oddly I would get on and I would
say like the one thing that got the most
laughs is like I was I is this was this
the six and a half stop like is this is
this the train to Hogwarts and so kids
would laugh at that and then I did
another one hey I ordered an uber pool
but they sent me the subway car so that
got some last those are like the main
two things I laughs you have to be so
comfortable with your vulnerability
though but I was it it's like I was with
a friend of mine and and and this person
brought on a video camera just so I
could study it later and I got on and I
I'm like forget it we just wasted our
time Ike you could just put the camera
away and I was like uh and then I said
on second thought just turn it on and
let's just wait a second mmm so my
friend turned on the video camera and
then I just went off so just right I
wasn't
I just went without thinking and and you
know sometimes people will laugh and
sometimes people were like you know boo
like get a D so but that happened you
got to be okay with either one yeah you
gotta be okay with the other one I mean
that's the difference between true
vulnerability and what I see a lot of
now which is I call it performative
vulnerability it's sort of like now it's
cool to be vulnerable all of a sudden
and you see a lot of people using it in
a very I feel like disingenuous way like
oh like when you're vulnerable online
that's how you get people interested in
what you're doing so I'm gonna do this
and it's it's like this weird like fake
vulnerability yeah and I see that it's
almost like you can't if you pick up a
recent self-help book or any almost any
reason self-help book and I'm not gonna
throw the whole industry owners of bus
but a lot of reasons self-help books
you can't even the author always starts
off like well I was in my darkest moment
and then XYZ happened and I started
writing in my gratitude journal and
whatever and I let everything became
better and it's like that's like a bad
and then even in Silicon Valley it's
like a badge of honor like yeah I held
up my first startup and blah blah blah
and then now now I'm ready and yeah I
agree I think it's a way to kind of
almost by it's almost to transaction all
the vulnerability right
yeah transactional I think is a good
word and hand in hand with that I get
I'm sure you do too like I get all the
galleys in the mail now yeah when you
host a podcast like suddenly books just
arrive at your house all the time like I
get like six books a week in the mail
and generally they'll be you know the
the upcoming self-help books right so I
have so many self-help books being
delivered on the regular here that it's
made me very cynical about oh yeah you
know I just look at this and I'm like
they're all they all in it and I can't
possibly read all of them but maybe you
can but
though it's kind of hates through them
and I'm like they just feel like
different flavors of the same thing and
it's made me like less interested in all
of that yeah that's why I think we'll
look at you know for instance binding
ultra or in my upcoming you know skip
the line I think about this what are
forget about all self-help what are my
real stories for better or for worse and
what did I learn from them and what can
i extrapolate the extrapolation is what
gives it the self-help categorization
like okay I did this this and this so
that's a formula but I always say I'm
not giving advice this is what worked
for me specifically but maybe it's broad
enough it could work for others and I
always want to make sure it's it's just
not like there's a not only was there a
self-help genre but they all kind of
recommend the same thing and and you get
this sense they're recommending it
without real experience or they're
recommending it so they can start
getting speaking gigs talking about it
cuz you can make a lot of money talking
you know motivating companies and so I
always try to make my make sure I'm
saying something really unique like this
this ten thousand you know thinking
about learning in the 10,000 hour rule
and how I could succeed like you went
through this in your mid-40s you left a
profession and kind of started you where
you did start new professions and that a
lot of people are going through that but
they always think well I'm already 45
how am I gonna learn to be the best or
the top 1% of some fields so people so I
can make a living at this because you
need to be in the top 1% roughly to to
make a living and to feed your family
and we're going through it just
personally and as an economy and so
really grappling with that and how I
challenge myself to learn different
things and how I failed at many things
in the along the way I had to think well
what's what's happening did and that's
where I went from the 10,000 hour rule
to am I can I borrow hours or is there
like shortcuts or cheat sheets or what's
actually happening you have to really
think inside what happened to me that I
can bring out as a story and I feel like
you did that to it with binding ultra
was your unique path to
hey at 45 you could still be a top you
know world-class athlete and do these
things and get over these issues and
change careers and on and on and on yeah
but I think my book was really just a
story where as you look at these things
that have happened in your life and you
look at other successful people and
you're trying to extrapolate the themes
and the lessons and then figure out a
way to communicate a path forward
through a lens or a you know a path that
perhaps has never really been fully
articulated like the skip the line book
that you have coming up like I've read
it yet but you've told me a little bit
about it and I think it's interesting
because it's about it's about this very
thing of like look we're in a rapidly
changing world where we're gonna be
compelled to have to reinvent ourselves
we're living longer etc and you don't
want to just have to switch gears and
figure out a new career later in life
and start at the bottom you're somebody
who has had success in a variety of
disciplines without really having to do
that without putting in 10,000 hours and
somehow found your way into that like
top tier that top 1% of these
disciplines so what was it what was the
differentiator here and what can be
learned from that experience that could
be helpful to other people yeah and I
think and look there's other things too
that I've massively failed at so you
sort of learn along the way I better
restrict my failure so I don't lose
everything on this failure so you have
to also construct ways to get better at
something where you're not risking your
entire life and like you even said
earlier you the transition from lawyer
to you know everything else you're doing
now it took a while like people kind of
think oh well I'm gonna quit being a
lawyer and start being a podcaster and
the one he's just gonna roll it it
doesn't really work like that for
anybody in the world yeah you know it's
it's it's a process and and it's a
process of trying lots of different
things it's a process of transition it's
a process of finding more and more
things that you enjoy and that you love
doing and that your your passions maybe
lie and
and maybe when you find something you're
passionate about you you're able to to
double down on it enough so that again
you're not risking too much but you
double down and you see how how it works
and how it feels and it's a process yeah
so you've got this book about
billionaires think like a billion yeah I
feel like culturally we were in a moment
where we're fetishizing these people and
on both sides yeah both sides meaning
what like some people you know you'll
see politically people will say well
banish all billionaires or like right
somebody in politics said and this is
not I'm very apolitical but so no
politics said you know billionaires have
not earned the money they took the money
so there's a very kind of almost violent
revolutionary backlash against these
people who have accumulated this one
particular number or more and on the
flip side you can say well these are
people perhaps who have accumulated
certain habits that maybe you'd want to
emulate if you wanted to success even if
it wasn't success about money and then
you can also say okay well are there
benefits to this this class of people
who have accumulated so much wealth are
they giving to charity are they solving
world problems are they creating impact
more than if the money was being used in
other ways and I shouldn't even say say
being used because often money is
created that's something that's a lot
he'll don't understand about the economy
there could be more money next year than
there then there is this year because
people people who are innovative use
their innovations to create money
seemingly out of thin air but you know
if Elon Musk sells more Tesla's and he
raises money by having an IPO and this
Tesla goes public and whatever money is
basically created and put some to some
extent put into his pocket so it's not
like they took they've created it out of
their innovations but sometimes they're
bad guys and sometimes they're good guys
like anyone else I mean there is a sense
I think that you don't get to that level
of wealth and accumulation without
stepping on a lot of people and having
to do some dastardly things yeah I think
that's I think that's kind of the sense
and it's easy to have that sense because
let's say there's a few thousand
billionaires and there's 300 million
other people in the u.s. so we're all
allowed to
trash this they're certainly not a
minority just because even though
there's just a few thousand I'm they're
very they're people who are very
privileged and benefit and and they have
every advantage in society and by the
way some of them are really bad people
but some of them are enormous ly
charitable like you look at efforts like
Bill Gates and again I don't know if
whether you like Microsoft Windows or
not but you look at Bill Gates he he has
spent hundreds of millions or billions
to try to eradicate malaria in Africa
and yeah you ask yourself well if if the
money had gone to a government instead
of Bill Gates with that government have
been able to solve malaria as well I
don't know I'm not an expert but it
seems like Gates has made a dent on it
and nobody else historically
has made a dent on it and and I heard
one interesting story where Bill Gates
gave like a hundred million dollars to a
government just like the US might give a
hundred million dollars to the
government let's you know here's aid
solve malaria and then that particular
government was corrupt the leaders left
and the money was just gone not spent
disappeared probably into some Swiss
account the leaders moved away and
whatever so the next leader got in and
Bill Gates said okay
I'm gonna give you 100 million again but
now I'm gonna have more control over it
and see how you spend it and see where
it's put and he made a dent in
eradicating malaria in this particular
country so you you have to look at
instances too and see what's what's
happening what are these people doing
with the money right but isn't Bill
Gates more of an outlier in that regard
like there's a lot of you know there's a
lot of guys with you know lots of yachts
and yeah I would say he is an outlier
you know but there's also you know
there's thousands of billionaires so
let's even say there's a few hundred
outliers who are trying to do charitable
things and by the way I'm not trying to
really the purpose was of that book was
to say okay I've been so bad and such a
failure at dealing with money maybe I
could learn what did they do that I
don't do that's I could learn from so I
really had nothing to do with whether
they were good or bad and so I always
feel like I'm apologizing so not about
making money it's about rabbits Anna and
a perspective on on life and how they
kind of live their day on the day
that right that lead them in that
direction right like not a single thing
in that book is about well this is the
kind of investing they did and this is
the kind of companies they would start
and here's how they would boss people
around but but just on the the Bill
Gates thing yes he's probably not a liar
but you do see lots of examples of of
charitable things or even let's say not
charitable like you know ken Langone
multi billionaire started Home Depot he
he saw a problem which is that many
people didn't have access to the full
range of home improvement tools that
they would probably want and he created
Home Depot it became big and hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of jobs were
created just just you know maybe
millions of jobs over the 30 years Home
Depot has been around and you know over
a hundred thousand people got very
wealthy by being employees of Home Depot
so he created real wealth in society he
solve lots of problems now ken Langone
almost every hospital in New York is
named after him because he gives so much
to charity and I don't really know him
so I can't say good or bad but again I
asked myself well ok it seems like both
from the capitalist side he created lots
of jobs and he solved a big problem
there's also charitable what then I
asked what habits did he have that maybe
are worth emulating and if somebody else
is a different opinion of him that's
fine but then I can say well I like
these habits and I'll emulate them
having a strong family for instance or
having you know a strong ability to
execute on ideas which is something I
didn't always have right I mean you kind
of break it down you've got like
obsession and you know overcoming
resistance persuasion empathy
problem-solving and this idea of skill
versus habit which I thought was super
interesting yeah like it's not like
these people have a lot of these people
have real skills as opposed to just oh
they're waking up at 6 a.m. every day or
they're you know going to the gym every
day these are all good habits and
healthy habits to have but how did it
original Branson persuade some of the
Boeing to lend this 27 year old nobody
an entire plane like 150 million dollar
plane I can't call it Boeing and just
ask for a plane like they'll hang up I
mean you tried to buy Greenland why not
oh yeah it's true
the whole was that there was an
anti-competitive climate at the time
well was that his ace in the hole or did
he find that in the hall like he was the
one who brought that up to them like he
basically would said no and he's like
well listen how else are you gonna
compete and get competitive pricing with
British Airways so he could put this in
their heads and convinced them and so
it's it's interesting to see the little
nuances of how these people achieve
things because it's it is nuance each
each skill they had you know their
skills at persuasion or sales or
execution or having creative ideas or
even the way they would do things like
so you know Daymond John's an
interesting example he was he was a
waiter at Red Lobster and on the
weekends he would sew these hats on his
corner and they had like hip-hop logos
on it and then suddenly Macy's makes
this hundred thousand dollar order and
he doesn't he can't make a hundred
thousand dollars worth of hats his work
works full-time as a waiter at Red
Lobster so what did he do he said of
course I will give you a hundred give me
a week I'll get you a hundred thousand
dollars worth of these hats he had no
reason to say yes and and and then he
goes to his mom he's like mom I need to
mortgage your house and Seymour's his
mom's house gets you know the money out
hires a bunch of seamstresses and they
work you know 24 hours a day in his
mom's now mortgaged house and then a few
days later he delivers the goods to
Macy's they give him the hundred
thousand dollar check he pays off the
bank gets picked the mortgage back and
now he has food which goes on for 6
billion dollars in sales so what is the
skill in that is that that skill is what
I call ready fire aim so this kind of
instinct to get all ready like he knew
he sold Pat's
$100,000 worth of hats to Macy's he
hadn't yet aimed he had no idea how he's
gonna do it but he fired he said yes
I'll do it and and not this why is that
a skill because he knew there would be
some way he can connect the dots and you
probably already had thought it out but
he knew no matter what there would be
some way he could connect the
dots and a lot of people would say I
can't sell you $100,000 where they
believe me I could sell you a thousand
dollars we could do a test or whatever
he he just went right for it and so Sara
Blakely who you know she's the founder
of Spanx she had a similar thing Jesse
hits less boy Jesse Jesse I'm sure he's
been on my guess is that I mine a bunch
of times and she was selling fax
machines door-to-door yeah this idea for
Spanx she goes to sell them she only has
her one example Spanx the woman tried it
on and said yeah I'll buy 300 thousand
dollars worth of it and Sara Blakely was
like done I'll get it to you right she
had no manufacturer she didn't know how
to manufacture clothes at all and it's
it's not easy to convince some factory
to manufacture all these these clothes
for you are you gonna pay the whoa who
are you you're not a real company and
yet she found a manufacturer she
delivered the the clothes then Spanx was
in business so that was again this ready
fire aim ability but ready fire aim has
to be underpinned by a profound sense of
belief in oneself right believed the one
job you're not gonna you're not gonna
move forward on ready fire aim unless
you you like have some level of deep
conviction about what you're doing yeah
and and it and she Sara Blakely and
Daymond John in this case had had enough
experience with let's say clothing and
clothing design to roughly know how they
were gonna connect the dots
maybe they fully know but more likely
they roughly knew how they could do this
how they could scale what they were
already doing to something a hundred or
a thousand times more and so you you
needed this confidence but you needed
knowledge too so another example is
Byron Allen he recently a few years
where he bought The Weather Channel for
300 million dollars so he started out he
was a stand-up comedian actually was the
youngest guy ever on the Johnny Carson
show and and then he had all sorts of
weird experiences in comedy and he said
you know what I don't want to be in
front of the camera I want to be behind
it I want to be the business guy that's
where the power seems to be so he
started pitching these shows late night
shows to television networks and I'm
like now this sounds kind of weak and he
said don't worry about it you don't have
to buy the show let's just do a 50/50
split on the ads and then
he found the advertisers and it cost the
station's nothing if you didn't come
with the money they would never have air
to show he kept fighting the advertiser
and it's like 25 years later these shows
are still running and he's accumulated
so much money for them that he bought
the Weather Channel for 300 billion and
he's bought other networks it's such a
crazy story
because if you don't know that story
he's just the weird guy at 3:00 a.m. you
cuz that show is still on I think turn
it on well yeah yeah he's interview
you're like who that guys still doing
that and it's kind of like it's not
really a quality good show and you're
like the show's been on for like 20
years like how is this possible well
it's because he owns everything yeah and
he sold all the ads and you know at that
time a lot of networks and still do they
they just have infomercials for a
half-hour so he they basically say to
him if you work we're running the
infomercial unless you show up with like
one penny more we're running the
infomercial so he just went out there
got the advertisers and got syndicated
all over the United States created you
know yes networks I think it's the name
of his company and yeah he was like a
fair-to-middling stand-up comic who was
part of that whole like Comedy Store
you know ecosystem and I'm sure
everybody told him he was insane for why
do you know why nobody would even think
to do that
yeah and it's scary too didn't all these
instances there's a little bit of a fear
factor like oh gosh what if I don't
raise the money but he limits his risk
it's like he doesn't have to put
together the show either really first
off you see those shows they're really
cheaply done it's just yeah they're like
a podcast on TV and and but he he went
out and sold the advertising and again
that's ready fire aim but there's also
skills in sales creativity persuasion
and knowing what doors to knock on and
and if that didn't work I'm sure he
would have found some other thing we
think that's like their one idea and if
they didn't do that they would have been
a failure now my guess is all three of
these people Daymond John Sara Blakely
Byron Allen they probably would have
succeeded at some other idea of that one
had it worked right well on this theme
of experimentation you you decide to
publish this book on script yeah so
that's so bizarre yeah so so would you
do that I've so I published mainstream
quite a bit and
self-published quite a bit so choose
yourself was self-published and actually
is my best-selling book and I was the
smartest thing you ever did yeah that
was yeah that was basically I'm so glad
I self-published that one and I did what
I called professionally self-published
choose yourself like I hired a real
cover designer I hired real editors I
hired a real marketing company and I
really did it as if I was a publishing
company even even better than him what I
thought a publishing company would do
and it and it worked really well but for
this one I felt like you know I've
already done one route I've done another
route I want to experiment a little bit
and Scribd
is like this Netflix for books you sign
up and whatever there's million yeah you
can read every book that's been
published ever or close to it and they
just started doing kind of like what
Netflix there was shows they started
creating their own original books
cribbed originals and sighs they
approached me I was I was telling this
CEO about this book and he said well how
about we publish it as a script original
and I said okay and so it's an
experiment and it's kind of six months
exclusive there and it's great so I
really enjoyed the experience I've done
you know a part of the experiment was
what are the benefits well they have a
million plus subscribers that get their
emails oh so my name will be on an email
to a million people so just more you
know this is not the last book I'm ever
doing or it's not the first book but
it's nice to have exposure to an
additional million size audience and to
build a relationship with this Netflix
of books depending on you know they seem
to be continued growing and so yes just
another experiment and are you happy
with how it's working out there like is
there a sense that this was the right
move versus just putting it up on Amazon
as a self-published work yeah cuz on
Amazon again I'm like every other book
out there and it's not like I'm against
Amazon I love publishing there and I
left self-publishing there but here's a
case where I'm one of the only books in
this category of Scribd originals in a
website that you know maybe up to two
million people go to all the time so I
figured let's see if this is a real
advantage and you always want to go to
the room least crowded so when we were
doing when we start doing podcasting
particularly when you started doing it
this is this was the room least crowded
in media now
very crowded but is like you said
earlier it's good thing we got here when
it wasn't crowded so we could carve out
our space and here I'm on script that
that's in publishing so I don't know
something like 5 million books a year
published now on Amazon a lot of them
self-published ok here's a place where
there's only four books published in
this way right you know they all the
mainstream published books are on script
city is much higher yeah for for having
something breakout meaningful way and if
the book failed completely okay it'll be
like eighteen of my other 22 books
completely right so this is no big deal
one of the things that I think we we
share in common is is an aversion to
setting long term goals like I don't
know about you but people ask me all the
time like what's the what's your vision
like where do you see yourself in five
years or what you know what what's your
life like in 10 years and I honestly
like I always feel guilty or perhaps
even ashamed because I I don't even
think about that like half the time I
find myself like making something up to
answer the question and I've realized
more recently like I'm just gonna be
honest like I don't I have no idea and I
don't really expand mental energy in
that way that's why I didn't know that
about you because I do think a lot of
people talk in terms of well I want to
be here in three years and then six
years of the ten years and and then well
in order to be here in ten years I've
got to do this today and like next month
and whatever and I think it makes no
sense to have goals it sort of implies
that my knowledge now is so much greater
than it might even be in ten years from
now that my ten year from now version of
myself better listen to me now because
I'm smarter now in terms of where I
should be in ten years I don't know if
this is law adding up all the numbers
but basically you're learning more every
day
so tomorrow or next month I might know
something about myself and my interest
in my passions or about the world that
changes where I want to be in a month or
two months or in a year so you can I
don't understand like how people could
even figure out how will they even know
what they want to be in one year or five
years well I think that goals have their
place like if you say you know if you
say like this is something I want to
manifest in the next year then there are
certain steps you're going to
to undertake to realize that like if I'm
if I want to do a crazy race for example
or complete a book like there are you
can set up benchmarks to lead you in
that direction and I think that's
completely appropriate but I think
forecasting a vision for your life I
guess it works for some people for me it
doesn't like everything that has been
successful in my life has been I
wouldn't call it happenstance but it
didn't result from me you know putting
it on a vision board yeah like like you
know I think that's a good difference
between goals and what was the word you
just used stepping stones no benchmarks
no but but but like that inspirations
you know there's a difference between
having something that you're moving
towards today so like let's say you want
to get a faster running time for a
marathon okay you could adjust things a
little bit and how you're running and
today you're gonna try this and see if
your running is faster but what if two
months from now and and all of this
could be because a year from now you
want to enter in this marathon and do it
faster than a certain time but what if
two months from now I don't know Disney
calls you up and says ritual we want you
to play Iron Man's father in the next
Iron Man movie and you're like well I
was gonna do this marathon that's my
goal so like call me back in a year you
want to do that you would just change
now that's an extreme example but yeah
so today you could say well I really
want to benchmark myself against how I'm
doing a race and I'm gonna improve
otherwise you would just there's no
reason to do anything but things change
and the things you love doing change
what if suddenly you decide oh man I
really love writing cookbooks and you
decide two months into the year I really
just want to spend this year all my
creativity writing cookbooks in that and
your goals change so the year I started
more passionately doing stand-up comedy
my goal so to speak for the year was I
was gonna write out a novel that was
where I was gonna put my creativity but
then I just started going up more than
once a week on a stage and then I got
heckled once and I'm like you know what
I'm I'm gonna just next week I'm gonna
come back three times
to figure out why I was heckled and I'm
gonna talk to people and think about
this and it just never stopped I never
got back to writing that novel things
change but ultimately the fidelity is to
your curiosity right and I think when
you when you double down on your
curiosity and you have the willingness
and the tenacity to follow that like to
continue to pull on that thread it
creates a compounding interest that that
in a real world context shows up in
opportunities that you couldn't have
predicted or imagined yeah like let's
say for instance Greenland suddenly
James we now were interested yes so
suddenly or or let's say suddenly out
somebody says you know this is a great
idea how about we write a movie about
somebody who buys Greenland and what
happens right and okay I'd actually
worry
yeah like well I would say yes to any
possibilities instead of going back to a
stand-up stage you know it just because
you sort of fall in love with different
things and you experiment enough with
enough things that you know you figure
out oh yeah this is pulling me a little
bit more so I'm gonna double down on it
and then everyone say well what wait a
second you were just doubling down on
this other thing no no now I've really
feel more passionate about this so again
as long as you don't say and I'm not
gonna take care of my kids anymore I'm
gonna backpack around the world there's
certain responsibilities that you have
to do but again with given our
creativity is very free we could do what
we could spend it in most cases how we
want and you should try lots of things
and and see where your your heart is
kind of compelling you to go further
even whether you're failing or
succeeding at that point doesn't matter
it's like where you want to get better
this is fun when it when I'm doing it
and it's not fun when I'm doing other
things right in thinking about this
podcasting space I think there's how
many podcasts are there now like I hate
to a million two million a million
podcasts like how many hours of people
talking spontaneously about whatever's
going on in their mind and I thought the
other day I thought what if podcasting
existed in like 1780 you know what what
if what would podcasting look like in 18
like if we could go back and just
two people talking about the times in
that time what an incredible historical
record that would be that would shape
and and and change how we think about
history and how we consume history and
how we synthesize world events and now
we're creating that now like a hundred
years from now this will all still be
you know available to people yeah back
on and and try to you know better
understand you know this moment in time
yeah I mean you know imagine back in the
1780s like just Benjamin Franklin and
John Adams would be having like hey you
know what if Marcus Aurelius instead of
like you know writing his meditations
was doing a podcast about it yeah Seneca
can you please come on a podcast I'll
promote your notes of Seneca we'll talk
about it everywhere and yeah and you
know I wonder about now with 2 million
how do you separate out the good from
the bad and and I don't like to call any
of them bad like everyone's trying but
I'm again it's like we were talking
about earlier I'm trying to just always
understand formats and how much you know
how can I change the format it just
slightly even from my usual one and I
you've been doing a lot of great stuff
with YouTube and videos like you've been
combining kind of your podcast voice
with a kind of more conceptual video
about what you're talking about you just
started doing that and I want to do more
of that but that's that's an experiment
yeah it's totally an experiment how long
will you do it maybe you do ten of them
five of them 50 of them and people will
say well no you got to be consistent in
focus
that could be true it may be you need to
do a thousand of and then it just
something you have millions of views per
video but you might get tired of doing
them after 20 and you say now let's
let's focus on tick-tock instead so or
whatever you focus on next and so yeah
it's just a matter of I'm always it's
interesting now too because another
thing that's happened in the media world
that's changed which is that I think
followers don't matter anymore so people
have you know X number of Twitter
followers YouTube subscribers Instagram
followers Facebook followers I don't
think that matters anymore because I
think algorithms have have basically
ruled over followers so
so the algorithm will decide where your
who sees your video or who sees your
photo not so much your followers because
if you have let's say you have a hundred
thousand followers or even ten thousand
followers and let's say a lot of them
have hundreds of followers and they're
on Instagram for three minutes the
algorithms got to pick which one of
their followers are going to be rewarded
with their eyesight so I think it's very
hard in today's world to come up with
good appealing content that rises to the
top and it's it's in a good way it's
much more equalitarian everyone's got an
equal footing because followers don't
matter as much on the second hand it's
harder to curate I think well it it
makes it right for trying to manipulate
it becomes about manipulating the
algorithm yeah I think that leads to
substandard content in order to game the
system but I think it is true like the
follower account thing I mean there was
a day you know in 2009 if somebody with
a million followers like retweeted your
tweet oh yeah you would you would
celebrate in five minutes you would get
30,000 new people following you like now
every once in a while somebody of that
stature will share something that I've
done at zero impact yeah anything you
know it's like that ship has sailed and
I don't have a huge Facebook following I
think it's like a hundred and thirty
thousand or something like that it's
substantial but I'll post the podcast on
Facebook and it'll get like two shares
yeah I'm like it'll be and it'll show
you how many people it sees it and it'll
be like four hundred people it's like
unless you pay to boost this stuff or
create ad campaigns around it they just
choke it so I try try that too I pay ad
campaigns sometimes around the podcast
does it useless doesn't work like hey so
uh fifty thousand people view it
magically I don't know who these 50,000
people are and it doesn't matter yeah so
five people clicked on it right so so
it's not even has nothing to do with the
content I don't know what it has to do
with and and I'm pretty sure I'm
structuring these ads right but I don't
know all that it's always important to
still have as high quality as possible
but other things are sort of rising to
the top of importance and it's they're
harder to figure out and I don't like
the idea it's even hard to game the
algorithm but I don't even like thinking
in that way so I never think about it
yeah
ultimately like I think you know people
will say oh you should do this and you
should here's the strategy and here's
how you should lay out your Instagram
and I just can't I can't wrap my head
around any of that and I just believe to
this day even if it's hard that
ultimately you know the highest quality
content will rise to the surface and it
will find its audience and that means
that you have to be in it for the long
run and you have to be patient and you
can't be upset if it's not getting the
nut you know the the level of attention
that somebody else who's who's
specifically crafted content to create
some level of virality is gonna get ya
and so what's interesting there is you
have a specific point of view also so
you're you're not you're not just hoping
that the quality is is gonna get a lot
of people you have a point of view that
people if they oh they want your point
of view they have to listen to you and
so it could be you get let's say a
hundred thousand super loyal people
listening to your podcast and you say to
yourself why does this other person have
a million people well they're just
talking about I don't know the election
every day and then those people are
gonna disappear they're not they're not
saying anything unique it's just to get
in giving the latest news or whatever
and you know so I think sometimes even
measuring the number is the wrong metric
but we're used to it in this social
media world how many followers how many
subscribers how many downloads and you
have to get back to like well have only
a thousand people like me but they
really love it I mean I think that's
more valuable yeah III honestly yeah
that my ego always wants something to be
bigger and to be growing at a certain
trajectory but ultimately what's
meaningful about this work that that you
do and that I do is the capacity to
impact people and to the extent that you
can improve the quality of the work to
to exacerbate that impact in a positive
sense so that they're left with
something substantial that really can
move the Neill and how they live their
lives that's that's the opportunity
there and so I try my best to like
remain focused on that yeah and and and
so let me ask you this has anyone ever
walked up to you and said oh my god
rich roll your Instagram changed my life
like has anyone ever said that's here
right with all cuffs
I bet you they have come up to you and
said ritual your podcast changed my life
yeah that happens a lot yeah and so
opens you yeah and and again no one's
ever said to me oh man your insulin I
love it I check it out every day like no
one said that and I have just as much
followers there baby as anyplace else
and you start to realize okay well why
am i pursuing that is it just for the
numbers or like really where where I
know where people are being impacted
because they tell me and so why am i
trying to get tik-tok followers or
whatever you joined tick-tock right yeah
I joined tick-tock and by the way that's
a very creative media I'm not lagging my
daughter they specifically prohibited me
from joining tick-tock now do they use
it and they don't like how they use it
they use it my younger one more than my
older one but she was just more like
because I was joking with her the oh
yeah I'm gonna join tick-tock I gotta
check this out you're not half joking
like that's kind of where I draw the
generational line you know it's like but
six I was really creative so I was like
I was kind of playing around with it and
and and and my youngest daughter was
just appalled she's like please don't
please don't
yeah I mean I was playing around with it
and then there I put I didn't have any
followers and I put up one video I put
up a couple videos in one video got
something like 200,000 views and so I
thought that was interesting that okay
there they're treating me algorithm
differently than other places well it's
it's Twitter in 2007 like the
opportunity to grow rapidly is available
on that platform because it's a new
platform right but then I looked at the
video that they get me the 200,000 views
and I thought man that is the stupidest
video I've ever done and so it's just
meaningless like so I'd rather just do
the podcast and not get were you like
dancing or something what were you doing
well that one people begged me to take
down and I did yeah like that I decide
okay this is beyond being afraid of what
people will think of me I'm making a
fool of myself so so I took that one
that were you telling you could tell you
could test out your material though I I
couldn't I've seen people do that and
kind of comedians it's interesting
because you saw kind of what I would say
were regular Club comedians
New York City going tick-tock and
suddenly get millions of views and
twenty fifty thousand followers and that
actually was an indicator to me that
this person was funny and appealing to a
certain audience and that that was a
data point for me when sort of seeing
could I own a comedy club too so that
was a data point for me and seeing oh
should this person perform or here or
not or whatever but for me I just put up
some articles that like an article I
wrote in 2011 I took it and just
basically set it in a tick-tock kind of
fashion and I got 200,000 views and
another one that was against college got
like a hundred thousand views or eighty
thousand views so I thought okay it's
interesting a little bit but not enough
but it would took a lot of time even
doing a 15-second video so I figured
okay it's not this is not worth really
doubling down on it's an experiment and
it right experimentation and I also
think it speaks to something that like
Gary Vee talks about all the time which
is not being romantic about the
platforms like whatever is working move
in that direction like you you do lots
of things but fundamentally I think of
you as a writer right and this is you
know you really develop your audience
through your blogging on your website
but then kind of blogging you know
really it's not like a thing anymore
right now to podcasting and that's a
problem with writing is that but like
writing should never go out of style yet
nobody is a blogger anymore yeah no
there's no destination blocks like it
used to be the case there's a
destination websites trying to get
people to go to your website is futile
yeah yeah go where everyone already is
yeah and so I think I mean then for a
while like places like LinkedIn and
medium works but I don't really see that
as much now so I don't know again it's
like people when people come up to me
and say oh I love X it's usually the
podcast and then one out of ten will be
writing and it's never anything else and
what do you think how do you think about
iterating on that going forward like
we're like forecasting we're podcasting
is going and perhaps you know being an
early adopter of whatever the evolution
of that is I think it's oh it's always
hard to predict like if you look at
what's happening now I mean so we were
doing the interview format a lot of
people do that and look the best that
the most
pure podcasts in the world you know Joe
Rogan show is the interview format so
that's kind of staying but people
talking I would I can't imagine is ever
gonna go out of style it looks a
substantive interesting entertaining
conversation yeah and then and then
what's what's interesting is that
storytelling is hitting the top 10 or
the top 50 of the top 100 so like true
crime story so it's like back to 1920s
dime novels about crime
that's what's shooting up the fastest
right now in podcasting and then I would
say also podcasts and I look at Joe
Rogan as an example podcast with a bunch
of comedians talking is interesting and
again Joe Rogan's got the most popular
podcast in the world and he's he is a
stand-up comedian often he has his
comedian friends on that's his who he's
interviewing and so I wonder if that's
because it's a safe place to to have
extreme opinions but not be accused of
being polarized in one way or the other
so like Joe and other people like that
will say whatever they want like it's
just insane what they'll say and if they
were like a big you know intellectual
order or whatever people say you can't
say that it's this you can't say that
about climate changes this is about
climate change you can't say this about
the Republicans with Democrats it's the
other way but Joe you can't ever figure
out because it about he his genius is
that you know he's the first hill to say
like well I'm a dummy comedian like your
why are you believing with anything I
have to say right and that's always his
refrain Jon Stewart says the same thing
throughout the entire work even though
everybody admitted they got all of their
news from The Daily Show Jon Stewart
would always say oh I'm not a news guy
I'm just a comedian but he knew we all
got our news from The Daily Show right
well in the way that that that the porn
industry drove technological innovation
on the Internet
comedians really are responsible for the
birth of podcasting like they were they
were the early adopter yeah like Marc
Maron as the guy yeah and like the early
days of podcasting it was almost
entirely comedians and you're correct in
that now what's capturing people's
attention beginning with serial are
these longer highly produced stories you
know our friend Neil Strauss did to live
and die in LA
- tremendously well and those are the
ones that are kind of rising to the top
so does that leave you thinking like
maybe I'll do something in that space
like the amount of work that goes into
crafting that like if even if you took
one interview and you like chopped it up
and then you put voiceover of you
contextualizing it kind of like somehow
the gimlet shows do it like I've thought
about that and I thought that's just
gonna take up too much time like yeah
this is already taking up too much of my
time I'm sorry about that well yeah and
you've gone - you're going to four times
a week with your show but but because
two of those episodes and maybe even
three is just going to be me bothered by
something and talking about it perhaps
with a boil perhaps someone's in there
who to tell me I'm wrong but it's not
gonna be the standard okay
gosh I've got to read 12 books you know
this week to prepare for my interview
subjects and it's exhausting yeah it's
exhausting so I kind of wanted to say
it's like what you were saying about
somebody said you know why were people
listening to you they weren't listening
to see what you were asking the other
person they really wanted to hear you
and so I figured okay let me just try
this I'm gonna say what I think is
important to me this week and why and
how I'm being impacted and kind of
storytelling about me a little bit or a
big need people have is like say say
when Iran happened so January 3rd you
know we attack this guy we kill this guy
and and my kids were saying to me is are
we getting drafted is there is World War
3 about to happen so there was this real
fear among everybody I'm you and I see
it even my kids and so I called up a big
military expert and I said just I don't
know anything and there's just a bunch
of what I call spectators out there
arguing all day long on Twitter and
Facebook like they know something just
let me ask you a bunch of questions
answer them and now I'll know some more
and so that's what I did and I think
calming people down is a good role for
podcasters with an audience if you can
get those guests and not have a
traditional guest but like this is
really scaring me right now let's break
down what's happening I think that's an
easier format to prepare for because I
know what I'm scared of and I'm gonna
try doing that a little bit more as well
yeah I think that with that
then you have to embrace the idea of
doing this contemporaneous with current
events like I'm trying to do interviews
that that withstand the test of time and
have an evergreen nature to them and you
know I've banked a bunch of interviews
and sometimes there's a long waiting
period between they go and I and then I
feel bad about it because yeah I know
wait are you ever gonna put that thing
up that we did and trying to find a way
to be more facile with it so from time
to time and I can make I you know I can
do a more current event oriented kind of
show I've also I've done I think I'm at
543 right now it's Alban evergreen but
I'm trying every now and then to be a
little current event just because
sometimes people are scared and there's
no one the media isn't properly
addressing their fears because
everybody's one side or the other side
and they're not just looking at facts
and also the media has incentive to kind
of exaggerate certain facts or change
certain facts and I'm up believing the
medium it's everybody and so sometimes I
just want to know should I be afraid or
not afraid so for instance you know
there's a lot of discussion lately about
well as AI and Technology gonna wipe out
30 million jobs in the u.s. like like
all these people are saying and so I've
been in the computer science industry a
long time ago but I called up current
experts in AI and automation just to see
where things were at and I found out and
got less afraid and was able to
communicate that so that's not going to
be evergreen but it's good to answer
this question for the next six months or
year that people have it right and so
sometimes now I'm just again playing to
see maybe I need to be a little bit more
current just to saw just to calm people
down on really super important issues of
all these ideas that you've put out in
the world what idea stands out as the
one that that people went the most crazy
about that like you shouldn't go to
college or okay no the what the most
controversial well the college one has
gotten me death threats so I saw early
death threats death threats so this is
crazy
this guy wrote me like you know set all
these things I'm gonna I'm gonna kill
you
and his IP address or whatever was on
the email somehow I was able to figure
out his IP address turned out to be
Brown University who's running from
Brown University and he put his name so
I called up so so my whole thing was is
that I don't think kids in today's day
and age not necessarily 30 years ago or
40 years ago but in today's day and age
kids shouldn't go to college because
it's reinforcing the system of higher
and higher tuitions an entire generation
of thirty million kids are going more
and more in debt which is gonna crease
income inequality and more and more bad
things will happen and and you could
learn these skills now from all these
online sites and but there's a societal
price anyway that's my whole thing I
college and this guy wrote write me
wrote me a death threat and so I called
Brown University police they put me in
charge of the the Chief of Police and I
should say allegedly Brown I don't know
if Ron will get upset at me so and and
and I I read the email and I said the
name of the guy and this is Chief of
Police oh yeah that's pretty bad and oh
by the way we we know that guy he did a
similar thing with the school librarian
and I'm like well shouldn't you do
something about this and he's like come
on it's it's March do you really want is
he's in his senior year just let him
graduate and and I'm like well he's
gonna graduate maybe yeah you know two
years from now he does something really
bad and nobody did anything right and
but there was nothing I can do really
like but the the thing that's gotten
people the most antagonist ik of all was
homeownership so I would write there's a
lot of financial reasons why you
shouldn't own a home there's a lot of
reasons why it's a really bad idea and
and people got really upset about that I
did it on Yahoo Finance it got over ten
thousand comments I got you know
millions of views and shares and and
I've written it as an article I've done
it as a podcast because that's the
biggest financial decision you make in
your life there's all this it's also a
source of tremendous pride for a lot of
yes so you're basically challenging
people's sense of themselves yeah and
and if you also spend that kind of money
your brains not gonna let you think
right day afterwards chested yeah yeah
you have an investment bias it's of
mental model and your brains not gonna
let you think you made a stupid decision
so people will fight that to the bone
like I've lost friends over that I've
lost friends over the college thing I
lost the most friends over though an
article I wrote on their you should
know war is ever really justified and
and I said I don't know anything I'm not
a historian but clearly like you go back
that has four or five wars they're
ridiculous and I'll even go as far as to
say why do we do the Revolutionary War
like clearly Canada didn't suffer
because they didn't have a Revolutionary
War and somebody would start writing me
well what about the Peloponnesian War
I'm like I don't even know what that is
so clearly it doesn't matter to me and
but then I did lose friends like
somebody called me up a month I realized
I hadn't heard from a friend in a while
and I call him like what's what's what's
wrong and he's like you're for you
you're obviously pro-slavery and I'm
like what do you how come what are you
talking about how got you personally and
he said you said no war can be justified
so that means the Civil War can't be
justified well slavery justifies it and
I said you could have just called me and
asked me if I think minority should be
slaves like clearly I don't and I said
well look at the you know England got
rid of slavery in 1831 maybe if we
hadn't done the Revolutionary War
there wouldn't be slavery because we
would've been part of England and I said
I don't know history I just feel like
when 20% of the country is died shooting
each other and it's all 17 year old kids
it's probably not the best idea that
maybe would have been another way to do
it by said I don't know I just think
kids shooting kids is a bad idea well
two things me first of all they these
friends that you've lost couldn't have
been you know great friends if that if
that was like a 20 year and ship I was
really surprised but he but he was of
Indian descent and you know took kind of
personal I understand and and I'm Jewish
I said look I don't think World War two
should have happened right but this is
like to know you is to know that that
you're very much a provocateur in this
sense like when I see like here's
another crazy idea that James has been
thinking about you know it's like you
put it out there and I think there's a
you know perhaps slightly unconscious
like Glee that you get from like let's
see what happens with this yeah a little
bit but I don't know try I don't say
things for ends I don't you know I don't
blindly disbelieve like you know you you
take you there's enough research to
basically connect the dots like what the
theory is first it's probably not a good
idea to send 18 year olds to kill other
18 year olds because bad things will
happen and then you have to look at
there's all sorts of ways to look at
every war but you I also know histories
were in by not just the winners but a
very tiny percentage of the winners
right history and they kind of make the
facts fit what happened now all of these
situations obviously everything was
horrible who knows what the right
solution was war turned out to be the
solution to some big catastrophic
problems it's just a thought experiment
what if there was never a war what would
what would it be like less people would
die so it's it's it's leveraging a
couple of the mental models that that
Shane parish talks about it's thought
experiment but it's also first-order
thinking like you're here's something we
accept that's just kind of locked in our
awareness as being true or just the way
it should have been or you know should
be or or is right and you're saying well
let's forget about that and look at it
completely differently yeah and then
taking kind of a counterintuitive
position on it yeah just so just
sleeping you know we dropped the atomic
bomb twice because the theory was that
oh and this is how history has been
written a million American lives would
have been lost if we did a full-scale
land invasion of Japan I don't know if
that's true no one's ever told me how
where the house numbers add up to a
million and and also there was a lot of
people arguing back then that maybe we
should just contain Japan until they
give up they're already kind of almost
giving up and so it's it's very unclear
what happened or why drop two bombs yeah
why you have two bombs they were
literally about to capitulate you can
argue and then they're gonna hold out
but we didn't need to invade them at
that point a million lives wouldn't have
been lost so who knows you always have
to question you know why are people
doing things in a certain way what's the
there's got to be a backstory and a
backstory to that and a flip story and
all this stuff we have no clue about
right all right well we got to round
this down but let's talk a little bit
before we end about your perspective on
on the biggest ways in which people get
in their own way yeah that's a good
question let me ask you like what do you
you know what do you think is the
biggest way you get in your own way
you've mentioned the couple you feel
yeah imposter syndrome I'm uh I'm
insecure I'm you know sitting here
looking at you but I'm thinking like do
I sound like a dummy you know like what
what's the next question can I keep the
momentum of this guy you know like I get
up in my own head and I'm my own worst
enemy by the way it's really hard being
a podcaster right you have to kind of
know you think Oh quiet that's when I
said wow you're doing four of these a
week like I've done Saturday Tuesday
Wednesday this is the fourth one that
I've done in five or six days it's hard
and I'm like tired yeah I know and I'm
like okay but James is coming gotta be
on my game so I can't imagine doing for
every week so that stamina endurance
contest in its own right but in terms of
how I get in my own way like I think
yeah I I'm profoundly insecure you know
like I have tools to keep those things
at bay and I'm very self aware of a lot
of these limitations but they still
affect my ability to you know kind of
optimize my what I'm trying to
accomplish I think I think but I think
you nailed it though with being
self-aware and not necessarily you know
it's it's everybody can say oh you need
to be more self-aware software software
and it's hard to do you have to really
be honest with what are my weaknesses
what are my strengths so I know I have
like huge weaknesses and psych
psychological issues around let's say
money I've gone broke so many times I'm
like literally afraid to look at my bank
account but you have this ability to
create money as well yeah I must because
I lose it all like you're like yeah but
I figured it news out somebody died
there's always a disaster every
I'm knocking a lot of wood right now but
also I think knowing being aware of what
you're interested in doing so one point
this is about a year ago I was pitching
a TV show and a network picked it up and
I thought to myself huh this TV show
idea is good but do I really want to do
it this is gonna take thousands of hours
of time I don't think I want to do it
and so knowing no knowing when your
heart once the deucedly when your heart
doesn't want to do something I think is
really important part of that self-aware
that's like a narrative show or no was
like a kind of social experiment reality
show I'll tell you the idea since I'm
not totally not doing it but I was going
to take six random people off the street
and the premise of the show was if they
followed my advice exactly I would make
them a millionaire within six months so
but you know some would bail someone
succeeds some would like beat me up or
whatever like you know typical reality
show stuff and I thought to myself
they won't networks not really gonna
know if this is good until it's over
until I've done it and what if it
doesn't work or it's just gonna take a
huge amount of time flying all around
the country that wanted people in every
city and and they wanted more than six
it's just they pick the best six so it'd
be so much work and I felt myself like
afraid of doing that much work so
ultimately it didn't happen but I think
also being aware of like what you're
willing to do what you're not willing to
do so the self awareness piece and that
is is the understanding like this isn't
really what I want to do and then
following that up with pulling the plug
on it even though it could be this huge
amazing opportunity yeah yeah because
look if there's a lot of ways to go for
making money making a TV show or doing a
podcast or going into stand-up comedy or
not or even being a writer those are not
ways to make a lot of money then you
don't go into those thinking man I'm
gonna make billions now forget being a
plumber now I'm gonna be a podcaster
it's just gonna start rolling in it that
just doesn't happen so so I think a lot
of it is about just being aware of what
your capabilities are what you really
want to do a versus what you're what you
don't want to do
understanding what skills you don't know
so somebody could say I want to be an
entrepreneur well what's what's
entrepreneurship there's no skill called
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship is
this bag of other skills like sales
ideas execution marketing motivation
leadership there's all these other
skills and added together it equals this
you could call it this one meta skill
entrepreneurship but that's not really a
skill so understanding what if you want
to do something what micro skills you
need to learn you have to avoid you know
and whatever you're doing you have to
avoid smoking your own crack like you
could think well I'm doing this so it
must be great and I see that all the
time among entrepreneurs or even
podcasters I'm doing this idea it must
be the best idea in the world why aren't
people coming to it I'm gonna have to
advertise now you should try to always
ask if if you're a smoking crack on your
ideas because I think that's a real easy
bias also that's a mental model as well
right right right
what do you think is your your greatest
strength like what is the secret James
all teacher sauce that that has
propelled you to this place I'm not I'm
not sure because I'm not so sure I've
done I'm not sure I've I've been
propelled anywhere but I think I'm I
think I have a lot of fun coming up with
ideas yeah so that's the thing I've
written about the most is like I write
down ten ideas a day and it just I
realize kind of shortly after I started
doing this that that just writing ten
ideas a day and it could be about
anything it could be about just oh ten
ideas for Valentine's Day guest tomorrow
or ten ideas that Google could do to be
better and they could all be bad ideas
but if you just kind of exercise this
idea muscle it really will get better
and if you don't exercise the idea
muscle it will atrophy so the times when
I was like losing all my money I was
letting my idea of muscle atrophy
instead of no matter what no matter how
bad things seemed I started always
exercising this idea I was writing ten
ideas a day down like I wrote ideas the
other day for I wanted to make this card
game again it's an experiment and I just
wrote the rules and that was my ten
ideas of the day and and so enough how
of those ideas how many of them do you
take action on one out of a thousand so
people say like how do you keep track of
the ideas and how do you know which ones
are gonna be good yeah you never take
action on them because it's really just
like if you exercise by lifting weights
it's not like you think the next day
well I don't have to lift today because
I lifted really but right yesterday yeah
it's just practice and and you'll know
the good ones because the next day
you'll figure out ten more ideas that
are about that it might be ten execution
ideas about one of the ideas from the
day before or a week before a month
before one of the ones I heard you
talking about recently was trying to pay
for stuff with North Korean currency oh
yeah yeah Iranian currency yeah so I I
on a fluke I will I wandered into this
random auction house it had currency and
I just this guy had like this bag of
money like just in like it was like this
old dusty store you could picture it
with all all these garbage bags to
little stuff and I started finding like
North Korean currency Saddam Hussein
currency Idi Amin currencies there was
all this like weird dictator money and
so I would I bought a bunch of it and I
started I figured it'd be fun idea to
videotape me trying to pay for things
like I hey I'm uh I go to buy a cup of
coffee hey I'm out of money but I have
this you know kim jung-il currency it's
ballot in North Korea and nobody ever
has taken money so they won't even touch
it right yeah some you some people it's
weird some just I think maybe they're
afraid it's infected with something or
there's some poise and I have no idea
like I think well if it's a gnarly
dictator money if it almost feels like
you're complicit in that regime if you
touch it
yeah with a Fender they think if they
touch it then that constitutes an
agreement or maybe also because there's
like sanctions that we have sanctions
against North Korea maybe you are
holding on to a bill for North Block
yeah but Donal make anyone thinks about
that it isn't weird it is an interesting
thing though yeah cuz I always ask
people why did you not care touch it and
they're like no I specifically don't
want but I probably don't have a good
answer for why
they don't nobody has given me an answer
yeah yeah they just don't want to look
like creeps them out what's the next
crazy experiment and then we'll finish
this thing well there's a lot really
there's this skip the line book that's
coming up and you're doing that with the
traditional publisher yeah
so almost an experiment to do what a
crazy experiment aims is actually gonna
go the traditional route well I really
wanted to see how things have changed in
that world and I think they have a
little bit but they and everything I
thought initially which is that they
rely on your marketing ability as well
is true so but now they just everybody
sort of knows the story like that's the
they know you have to do that and you
know you have to do it and and yeah a
lot of things I'm experimenting with
like I've been playing around with doing
this card game and now I know how to do
a Kickstarter because of Greenland so
I'm gonna do a Kickstarter for this card
game once I print up the first version
of it and that's just a fun thing the
key with an experiment is it shouldn't
take up too much time or money another
thing I've been doing is I've been
putting what I call anti ads on the
backs of cabs in New York City you ever
go to New York City and you see on the
back there's there's a little TV show
and there's ads and the ads will be for
real products so I've been creating
these ads that don't advertise anything
so there's just like it is just like a
picture of me saying hi and and and they
call me up they called me up and they
said you have to put a URL or do you
want to put a URL or a Twitter handle or
something and like no that's the whole
point no you're out no that's that's
like performance art yeah you don't like
that and I kind of want to see what
happens though like does it and I've had
at least one instance because I did this
for a couple months I'm doing this for a
couple months and one guy now did come
up to me last week and he's like yours
that yours that taxi TV guy my
nine-year-old loves you and he took a
selfie with me he didn't know my name
you know anything other than you said hi
and a little sticker yeah and there's no
and the taxi TV people said we can't run
this because originally I didn't even
have high on it and they said we can't
run this there's not sure of your face
yeah it was just a picture money and by
the way it was really like it was I was
wearing a white t-shirt and I was
standing next to a white background so
it was the worst
possible way it's a structure of photo
and the taxi TV people said we have to
have a certain bar we have you know
professional advertisers advertising on
this we can't run this so they made me
but and I and they had a good idea which
so they I can't say they made me but I
they said make it a little bit of a
sauce I put high on the first one and
like high again on the second one and I
forget what we put on the third one like
a math puzzle or something but so that's
an experiment I have like these are up
in New York right now cruzi around yeah
oh my god and I have like 20 of these
experiments going on these different
types of things like this they all seem
small and you know also working on
another TV show which should be much
less work and experimenting with the
format of the podcast and such things I
do all the time to figure out okay if it
doesn't take time or that much money I
can do it and so I do it I love it and I
love you you're funny you're fantastic I
love the work that you do and you know
what let me just say this you look great
and you seem really happy I'm happy to
say thank you rich I've been I wish I
could say I've been living your healthy
lifestyle but you're always I've know
you taking stabs out of it yeah I think
instead I remember one time you visited
me and you were talking and my my
daughter I have my red haired daughter
was about to turn full vegan and I think
you actually listening to you actually
put her over the edge like she was just
like lusus sitting there like wrapped
while you were talking and now she's
been like literally a vegan ever since
four years later I love it so so at
least she's living that lifestyle but
yeah I try to be healthy well we're
working this is this is this is perhaps
a new experiment for you yeah it could
be it could be alright man well to be
continued yeah definitely thank you as
always and I look forward to our our
next get together on the air sooner
rather than later yeah cool peace
[Music]